as the cycle of violence continues to
worsen in the occupied West Bank
Sunday's killing of three Palestinian
men will no doubt raise tensions even
higher
Israeli Army issued a statement saying
its Special Forces opened fire on a
vehicle carrying the men in order to
thwart a squad from the Janine refugee
camp that was on its way to carry out
what they describe as a terrorist attack
on
[Applause]
I heard the sound of gunfire and looked
through the window of the house and saw
special units some of them in civilian
clothes and some of them wearing army
clothes firing at a blue vehicle it was
shot many times
in response Hamas insisted the deaths
would not go unpunished while also
calling for the formulation of a
national plan to confront the occupation
at the site of the killing young men
raised the Palestinian flag
just a day earlier a Palestinian man
from Janine opened fire in central Tel
Aviv and killed an Israeli Police
Inspector before being shot dead by a
responding officer
that attack came 24 hours after a
rampage by settlers in the occupied West
Bank that resulted in the killing of a
Palestinian teen
one of the attackers is a former aide to
an Israeli far-right party
spiral of violence only seems to deepen
what the Israeli arm
and does will of course create responses
from Palestinians and acts of resistance
because today every Palestinian have to
fight for his life for the life of his
children for the life of his family and
for the protection of his house
Janine has been a flash point for months
now not just the Locale of near daily
Israeli raids but also the scene of a
day's long military assault on the
refugee camp there in early July at the
time a group of United Nations experts
said that Israeli airstrikes and ground
operations in Janine May constitute a
war crime as concerns continue to grow
here officials have warned that 2023 is
on track to be the deadliest year for
Palestinians in the occupied West Bank
since the U.N began keeping track of
fatalities in 2005. Mohammad occupied
East Jerusalem
foreign